how did Robert Downey Jr go from
battling personal demons to becoming the
iconic Iron Man we all love back in the
day RDJ faced his fair share of
struggles with addiction but once he
kicked those demons to the curb his
career soared to new heights Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang zodiac and Charlie Bartlett
put him back in the spotlight showcasing
his skills and proving he was back and
ready to take Hollywood by storm fast
forward to the casting of Iron Man and
you won't believe the twist a slew of
a-listers like Tom Cruz and Hugh Jackman
vied for the role but Downey Jr landed
it not because he was the obvious choice
but because he was an economical one